Sheila E opens up exclusively to ET
about princes private memorial service I
lost my friend I haven't even gotten
past that close friends and family
gathered at Paisley Park on Saturday to
pay their respects to the iconic singer
who died on Thursday Prince's longtime
collaborator Sheila E was there and
opened up to et on Sunday about the
emotional ceremony was very somber it
was sad and that's what was challenging
yesterday was listening to his music at
a very low South Valley volume in the
room very you know Lo and lights and
everyone just taking a moment just
sitting there just kind of going wow you
know disbelief I don't know that he
really knew how he touched almost
everyone in this world
the singers devoted fans are undeniably
in mourning but Sheila confirms some
uplifting news there are plans to turn
Paisley Park studios into a museum he's
been getting like Memo billion stuff
from all the tours like my drums his
motorcycle there's a hallway of you know
his awards and things which he really
didn't care about too much but he's
displaying it for the fans you know
because he knows that they would want to
see it there's pictures of him all down
the halls different pictures some you've
seen before some never and more a
tribute performance is also in the works
I'm supposed to be the one musical
director to put the his tribute together
with all of the original people and we
hope that that happens we're working on
it we'll see what happens that is the
plan is to have something here in
Minneapolis for more from Sheila E on
Prince's life and legacy tune in to e T
Monday April 25th